-I have so many things
to ask you.
-Sure.
-But I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so happy to be back.
-But, first of all,
even just doing that, I just
want to say congratulations.
You just got -- You got engaged.
-[ Laughing ] I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you!
-Oh, my gosh, yeah.
I'm so happy for you, pal.
-Thank you, baby.
Thank you.
-Now, there's --
There's been big news, recently.
They announced that
they're making a "Wicked" movie.
And Ariana Grande got cast to
play Glinda, which is your --
you made it famous
in the play "Wicked."
Did you --
Did you talk to Ariana?
Are you happy with the choice?
-Oh, I couldn't be happier.
I've known her
since she was 10, y'all.
She came to the show, and she's
like, "I want to be Glinda,"
in the same exact voice
that she has now, just like me.
And I said, "You can be."
And then, her Nana says,
"Oh, you gotta sing for her,"
and she did.
And she blew me away.
And I was like,
"You have to have
something of mine."
So, I gave her hand soap
and a fake plastic wand,
and I said, "Take it."
-Soap?
-Yes.
-Hand -- Hand soap?
-I just said, "Take my soap."
I know, it's weird.
[ Light laughter ]
-Does she remember that?
-Yes. She -- She said, for many
years, she didn't use it.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
This is a real photo of you.
-There's --
-And this is
Ariana Grande and -- yeah.
-And Nana.
-Nonna.
-And Nonna, right.
-That's right. Nonna.
Oh, no way.
-Look at her.
-Is that unbelievable, though?
-And now she's playing --
I'm so happy.
-Isn't that wild how life works?
That's wild.
-Yes.
That's when you know
you've been around a second.
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
But, I mean, also, to get the
thumbs-up from you is fantastic.
Now, the rumors are now,
are you gonna cameo
in the movie, or would you?
-Well, I haven't
thought about it.
But here's
what I think should happen.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know the poster,
how Glinda is always looking --
Yeah, thank you, thank you.
-I'm prepared. Yes.
-Yes, you are.
And, by the way,
I begged to have blonde hair
in this, 'cause I feel like
The Flying Nun,
but that's a separate subject.
[ Laughter ]
I always think --
I just thought it'd be cool
if the camera panned by
and Idina and I were just there
and we just --
you just saw me go -- yeah.
-[ Imitates whispering ]
That's a good -- Come on.
That's a good Easter egg,
right there, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I want --
I would want to see
a little bit more of you.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Thanks.
-Because -- yeah.
You know I love you.
I have a question
I want to ask you about.
-Okay.
-Because we both love him, but,
I heard that Prince
was a big fan of yours.
And --
-I -- yes.
It happened.
I dated him twice.
-You dated Prince?
-I didn't know it was a date,
because it's Prince.
-Yeah.
-So, the manager calls me,
and she says,
"Prince wants
your phone number."
I was like, "Yeah, right."
[ Snorts ]
[ Laughter ]
That's what happened.
-Yeah.
-And then, Ruth, his assistant,
called me and said,
"No, Prince, really."
So, I drive in my Honda CR-V
in L.A. up to -- it was
when he was the symbol.
-Yeah.
-To the symbol,
and I got through, and there was
a big purple carpet,
and a waitress there,
and I went in, and the -- the --
the hallway
was as big as this room.
And I hear --
I'm in the library,
and I'm looking at what
Prince is reading, right?
And I hear, "Click, click,
click, click, click, click."
-Yeah.
-It's him in his heels
coming toward me.
-Yes, that's right.
He wore heels.
Yes, correct.
-Which was fantastic for me,
because, you know.
So, he comes in, and I go,
"Hi. I'm --
I want to party like it's 1999
and ride your raspberry beret."
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers ]
He just was like, "Wah, wah."
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-And then we -- we had salmon,
and I hate fish,
and so I put it in my napkin.
[ Laughter ]
-I love these details.
-Oh, yeah.
I'll never forget, because --
-What does his -- what did
his place look like?
-It's -- It's a museum.
-Yeah.
-It was a museum.
A museum.
I mean -- then he said, "Do you
want to go see my guitars?"
I'm like, "No -- Of course!"
-Yes!
-So we go down to the basement,
which is massive.
And there's -- y'all,
probably 200 guitars lined up,
standing there.
And he said, "Pick one up.
What's your favorite?"
I picked up this white one.
Picked it up
and start playing a little bit.
I'm terrible.
And I couldn't believe
I played in front of him.
I mean, really.
And I turned it over --
it was really heavy --
and I go, "What's all this
scratching on the back?"
He goes, "Elvis's belt."
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Yo! That's a way
to say it, right?
That's how cool he was.
-Yes, I was practically like..."
[ Mumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
I'm passing out, you know?
-Oh, my --
-I'm so glad I didn't.
But -- yeah.
-Great story, though.
-Oh, I just couldn't
believe that he --
Oh, he took me down in the --
in the basement,
in a movie room,
and he said, "Watch this."
And he -- I did this opera
called "Candide" on --
and it was on PBS.
And he said, "Look at the --
You sing this aria.
You inspire me."
I'm sorry.
It's so weird to cry,
but I thought, "Are you insane?
I'm not watching myself."
And he said,
"What you do is what
I like to do with the guitar."
And anyway --
-Isn't that unbelievable?
-Isn't that cool?
-I love that story.
Thank you
for telling us that story.
-Of course.
-I appreciate it.
-I don't tell it very often.
-You know.
You can always tell --
that means more to me --
I get it, and I love it.
I appreciate it.
-Thank you.
I love him.
-I want to talk to you about
"Happiness is...Christmas!"
-Oh, right. That.
Right.
-That's why we --
we got to talk about your album.
I think this is a great year
to put out a holiday album.
-They -- They were like,
"What do you want to do?"
And I said, "I really
want to do a country album."
And they said,
"No, how about a Christmas?"
And I wasn't in the mood.
But then I start thinking about
light -- light at the end
of the tunnel, you know?
-Yeah.
-And that's why I did it.
-Yeah. Exactly.
Well, thank you for doing that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you.
Kristin Chenoweth, everybody.
"Happiness is...Christmas!"
is out now.